akira receives a prize at a science fair
for having the most informative project
her trophy is in the shape of a square
pyramid and it's covered in shiny gold
foil so this is what her trophy looks
like how much gold foil did it take to
cover the trophy including the bottom
and so they give us some dimensions and
we want how much gold foil and it's an
inches squared so it's really going to
be an area so pause this video and see
if you can figure that out how much gold
foil did it take to cover the trophy all
right now let's work through this
together and so essentially what they're
asking is what is the surface area of
this square pyramid and we're going to
include the base because that surface
area is how much it's the area of the
gold foil that is needed now some times
some of you might be able to think about
this just by looking at this figure but
just to make sure we don't miss any area
I'm going to open up this square pyramid
and think about it in two dimensions so
we're going to do is imagine if I were
to unleash or if I were to cut the top
and let me just in red if I were to cut
this edge if I were to cut this edge if
I were to cut that edge and that edge so
the edges that connect the pit be
triangular sides and if I were to just
open it all up what would this look like
so if I were to open it all up well at
the bottom you would have your square
base let me color that in so you have
your square base so let me draw that so
you have your square base it's going to
be a rough drawing and what are the
dimensions there it's three by three we
know this is a square pyramid so the
base all the sides are the same length
they give us one side but then if this
is three inches and this is going to be
three inches as well let me color it
that same color just so we recognize
that we're talking about this same base
and if we open up the triangular faces
what's it going to look like well this
is going to look like this this is a
rough sand drawing but hopefully it
makes sense this is going to look like
this
and each of these triangular faces they
all have the exact same area and the
reason why I know that they all have the
same base 3 and they all have the same
height 6 inches but I'll draw that in a
second so they all look something like
this
just hand drawing it and all of their
heights all of their heights are 6
inches so this right over here is 6
inches this over here is 6 inches this
over here is 6 inches and this over here
is 6 inches so to figure out how much
gold foil we need we're trying to figure
out the surface area which is we're just
going to be the combined area of these
figures well the area of this central
square is pretty easy to figure out it's
3 inches by 3 inches so it would be 9
inches 9 inches squared now what are the
area of the triangles well we could
figure out the area of one of the
triangles so they're multiplied by 4
since there are 4 triangles so the area
of this triangle right over here it's
going to be 1/2 times our base which is
3 times 3 times our height which is 6
let's see 1/2 times 3 times 6 it's 1/2
times 18 which is equal to 9 9 square
inches or 9 inches squared so it's going
to be our total area well you have the
area of your square base plus you have
the four sides which each have an area
of 9 so I could write it out I could
write 4 times 9 or I could write 9 into
that black color or I could write 9 plus
9 plus 9 plus 9 and just to remind
ourselves this is that right over there
is the area of one triangular face
triangular triangular face so this is
all of the triangular faces triangular
faces and of course we have to add that
to the area of our square base so this
is 9 plus 9 times 4 you could view this
as 9 times 5
which is going to be 45 square inches
nine plus nine plus nine plus nine plus
nine